[Música]
la lista de las cosas que hemos perdido
por 19 sin nubes larga y para muchas
personas es muy dolorosa pienso en
particular quienes han perdido un ser
querido un familiar a un amigo y a los
que hemos perdido la libertad la
libertad de salir a la calle o de
abrazar y besar a la gente que queremos
sin duda la llegada de este indeseado
visitante pues nos ha dejado con muchos
problemas tratar nos trajo algo también
que vale la pena valorar y que quiero
practicar es aquí que creo que podríamos
llamar como la nueva intimidad es una
nueva intimidad que en primer lugar
comienza con nosotros mismos porque
quizá por gusto o simplemente orillado
por las circunstancias hemos tenido que
pasar más tiempo con nosotros mismos con
nuestros pensamientos con nuestros
temores con nuestros deseos
hemos tenido que visitar la selva
interior algunos de lo mejor para
confirmar o descubrir que era muy fueron
12 que tiene áreas muy bien cuidadas y
otras a lo mejor no tanto o quizá otros
para confirmar que lo que tenemos de
jardín interior se parece más bien a una
plantita de plástico pero lo cierto es
que éste como éste hemos tenido que
visitarla
y hemos tenido que encontrar adentro en
nosotros en nuestras familias en
nuestras casas las respuestas que quizá
antes buscábamos de alguna manera pues
del otro lado de la puerta en las calles
en los viajes en las tiendas y por eso y
el mundo está viviendo este boom de las
clases de yoga de meditación de la
religión del mundo espiritual en general
porque cuando la respuesta no la puedes
encontrar allá afuera que se la tienes
que buscar aquí adentro para esta
intimidad no se ha llevado también a
establecer relaciones diferentes con
nuestros amigos los amigos claro pienso
en los que ya estaban con nosotros en
este momento pero también pienso en los
amigos que a veces o el tiempo o un
conflicto o la geografía habían alejado
cuatro de nosotros no hemos tenido en
estos días reuniones con personas que a
lo mejor hace mucho que no veíamos
porque es cierto que este periodo para
muchas personas es un periodo de pérdida
pero también para muchas personas este
periodo se ha convertido en un momento
de reencuentro en donde hemos sido
capaces de resolver las diferencias
diferencias a veces hasta de uso horario
para conectarnos a la misma hora
y yo no creo contra lo que la bajo
pudiéramos pensar que si esto ha
ocurrido porque hoy tengamos más tiempo
yo creo que lo que tuvimos por más ganas
más ganas de vencer las resistencias
ganas de poner ahora sí por primera vez
lo importante sobre lo urgente y ganas
de ser capaces de ver a la otra persona
si fuera a través de una pantalla y
miren yo entiendo a lo mejor habrá quien
diga oye pero que es lo novedoso de esta
nueva intimidad si a todos nos está
diciendo que somos cercanos de los que
ya éramos el cráneo de los amigos y de
la familia pero yo quedé nivel más y qué
tiene que ver con esto que a lo mejor
llamaríamos los conocidos estoy pensando
en esa persona del trabajo que lo mejor
de repente viste triste o bajoneado en
una llamada de una junta y que después
te contó que estaba así porque está
preocupado quizás porque tiene o tenía
un familiar enfermo y que hoy
construiste un nivel de vinculación de
empatía que no tenías antes pero pienso
también en esa maestra que quizás antes
de arrancarse con su clase como lo hecho
año tras año grupo tras grupo
ahora se sintió obligada a empezar la
clase preguntando oigan muchachos y cómo
están y es que quizás a diferencia de lo
que hemos vivido a lo largo del tiempo a
lo largo de nuestra propia vida hoy
cuando tenemos a alguien en frente ya
sea con el tapabocas con la careta o con
la pantalla en medio cuando le
preguntamos cómo estás a lo mejor de
veras tenemos interés en escuchar la
respuesta y la clave la clave de estas
nuevas relaciones que estamos
construyendo creo que es la palabra
vulnerabilidad hoy nos mostramos más
vulnerables que antes y quizás lo
hacemos porque sabemos que esta
preocupación que tenemos de contagiarnos
se contagia en cercano a nosotros es la
misma preocupación que tiene la vecina
con la que a lo mejor nos hablábamos
poco esto que hoy nos quita el sueño
porque no sabemos qué hacer con su
trabajo qué pasa con los ingresos con el
patrimonio pues son las mismas causas
que provocan el desvelo de ese otro
compañero de trabajo o de esa otra
persona y a lo mejor no era tan cercana
a ti y es que si algo ha tenido esta
pandemia su carácter demócrata
le pega los ricos a los pobres al primer
mundo al tercer mundo a todos y nos ha
recordado que más allá de las evidentes
diferencias que ahí están que ahí siguen
pues somos mucho más parecidos y tenemos
las mismas preocupaciones de las que
quizá antes por diversas razones nos
resistíamos a admitir pero déjenme
agregar un nivel más yo creo que todo
esto que estamos viviendo ha traído una
cosa que bien podríamos llamar la
intimidad pública aunque suene raro el
término y estoy pensando en eso que
hemos visto todos en las últimas semanas
a través de las pantallas de televisión
cuando vemos programas de tele programas
de radio mesas discusiones juntas
seminarios las reuniones hasta de la
oficina que hacemos a través de schumi
de estas plataformas porque algo ha
tenido este periodo y es que no
solamente nos metió en nuestras casas
sino que nos metió en las casas de las
demás personas y hemos podido ver la
vida de la gente pero desde una
perspectiva diferente a la que nos
habíamos contado en un largo de los
últimos años que lo hemos hecho a través
de las redes sociales porque ahora si
miramos a la gente
es la foto perfecta a través del filtro
no miramos la comida perfectamente
seleccionada sino que vemos una realidad
externa
es menos bonita de la que estábamos
acostumbrados a ver pero sin duda se
percibe mucho más auténtica es una
realidad mucho más real en la realidad
de la junta de trabajo de pronto
atraviesa el gato en frente de la cámara
donde la del perro donde el niño de
pronto reclama atención a la mejor a la
mitad de una junta importante en donde
de pronto el sonido de la calle se mete
también ahí y la pregunta que yo quiero
dejarles en esta sesión es que a pasar
después de esto qué consecuencias va a
tener esta nueva intimidad regresaremos
a ser como éramos antes de entrar en
esta nueva etapa
o quizás iremos un poquito más empáticos
seguiremos contando el mundo una
realidad perfecta a través de nuestro
instagram de nuestras redes sociales o
de pronto vamos a mostrarnos sin la
tiranía de la sonrisa permanente sin la
exigencia constante de la eterna
felicidad y quizá quizá de pronto
empezamos a tener diálogos personales
profesionales hasta públicos quizás
menos posados quizás diálogos más
auténticos a ver si no resulta en estos
tiempos de paradojas que este virus que
nos aisló este vídeo es que nos encerró
al mismo tiempo nos trae una nueva
intimidad que nos conecta más y que nos
hace más libres la última palabra por
supuesto la tendremos nosotros
[Aplausos]